bill shares joining me today he is
editor at our future dot org and
contributing editor at Politico bill
you've written a bit about the WikiLeaks
attacks on Hillary Clinton III believe
that these attacks backfired in the
sense that they only confirmed what any
reasonable person already sort of knew
or suspected about Hillary Clinton right
her ties to Wall Street the reality that
behind closed doors she said too many of
these companies hey you know what uh
it's not gonna be that bad i'm not gonna
be that hard on you if I'm president of
the United States I didn't really learn
anything that shocked me and I think
that that some people may have all sort
of overplayed their hand with regard to
the speeches and the WikiLeaks what do
you think well I generally agree with
that uh if you already suspected Hillary
Clinton was a calculating politician who
was too close to wall street uh and it
isn't motivated by philosophical
conviction but does everything based on
poll numbers uh you are you if you
already assumed that you could have your
narrative validated by the emails if you
feel that Hillary Clinton is simply a a
politician doing what politicians do
when there is no politician that doesn't
weigh those types of considerations and
there's no campaign staff that doesn't
speak in unvarnished pointed
condescending terms when we win
communicate privately you would all you
would also shrug it off so we had a two
week period after the Podesta emails
were leaked by WikiLeaks and Hillary's
numbers were slightly better after a two
week period now there's some question
how our numbers will hold up after the
James Comey statement but you have a
wheen two weeks is plenty of time to
assess what the wikileaks impact was and
it was not negative to Hillary and I
think that is relevant not just in terms
of who's going to win onto a Braith but
what is the power of cyber hacking and
cyber
warfare the general assumption obviously
the opinion of the intelligence
community is that this is uh led by the
Russian government that fed the stuff to
WikiLeaks that their agenda is not to
Elektra per se but to undermine American
and global faith and American democratic
institutions to make people think this
is rigged and this really goes on behind
the scenes it's a tour dates and it's
shady uh and therefore people will look
at America as being on a higher moral
authority on a higher moral plane then
Russia but if the impact of this is
people generally accepting this is what
daily political life is like if you if
you delete anybody's emails Republican
or Democrat liberal or conservative you
get similar stuff if you lit not to
mention rushing emails for that matter
uh that's not going to that's that makes
the tool of cyberwarfare less potent has
the race fundamentally changed in light
of the tightening national polls I mean
earlier in the show we sort of went
through about a couple weeks ago the
Real Clear Politics average had Hillary
Clinton closer to six and a half seven
points ahead last week that had been
reduced to around four and a half to
five and then as if this morning it's
like a 2.2% average lead for Hillary
Clinton in the polls it it's a pretty
significant change nationally it's not
creating a huge shake-up electorally
when you look at state by state polls is
it just too early to know really whether
these national poll tightening czar
going to have an implication electoral
II yep you look careful with the Real
Clear Politics average here is and i
should say one i may contribute to real
clear politics but two I'm not involved
in the poll averaging I'm not in their
newsroom i can't i can't speak with them
directly so i'm speaking as much like an
outsider like anybody else would uh but
i do know that yet the the specific
polls that get included in the average
rotate depending on which polls are
fresh I and there is an argument that
the current polls in the average are the
ones that have been more
republican-leaning to date uh now there
is like Rasmussen for example or the the
IBD TI PP tracking poll love that early
been favorable to 22 Trump now you have
this one example which is catching rays
tension which is the ABC Washington Post
poll which has not been a pro Trump poll
but it's had this very large swing over
the past week from + 12 Hillary to now
it's actually +1 Hillary in the two-way
in +1 Trump in the four-way uh most of
that shift is a before the komi
statement uh and so you and you didn't
see that it has that kind of massive
jump in other polling you're not seeing
it in the in the State polling uh I tend
to look at what i call the big five uh
which includes ABC Washington Post but
also CNN fox NBC Wall Street Journal at
CBS New York Times we haven't seen those
other four poles come out in a while uh
so I think you want to see a number of
higher quality polls which presumably
will come out between out election is
Lisa way days left before really saying
are we are we seeing a true tightening
here or are we or is this the same
stable race that we basically had for
the whole year where Hillary is in the
upper forties and Trump is in the lower
40s and he occasionally gets around 45
in the averages but never really seems
to break through when we talk about
claims of a quote rigged election with
regard to whether it's polling or
whether it's the management of elections
at the state level or as trout Donald
Trump is sort of uh intimated media
coverage that is negative about Donald
Trump I'm really struggling to
understand why if we are to believe the
allegation from some Trump supporters
and and even Trump himself that
corporate media is just out to destroy
Trump why have we seen almost no
coverage of the Donald Trump a child
rape case that is pending there's a
hearing scheduled for December 16 mean
if corporate media really just had it in
for Trump wouldn't they be talking about
that more
I would assume I have to say I I haven't
followed the shower package very closely
I've seen a headline here there but I
haven't I haven't personally dug into it
well that the problem it isn't it I mean
that's that's fascinating that you're
mentioning that I mean but I I take your
point obviously if you really had it in
for Trump you would you would do you
know seven days straight on that story
regardless of what the merits of the
case was because you had it in for now I
do think that Trump has had lots of
negative press but so as Hillary Clinton
they both have had an ordinance amount
of negative press uh I mean Hillary's
negative press goes from the beginning
you there was a good time in the primary
where Trump's press was wow he did
nothing affects Trump he defies the
rules of political convention he is easy
tha he's leading a true juggernaut and
Hillary is justice stodgy awful personal
the Democratic establishment who can't
answer questions about her emails me you
know we we have plenty of reporting
about her emails in the Clinton
Foundation and uh changes in her
position so you you really can't argue
that she's had some sort of free ride
here uh and Trump's negative coverage is
almost solely all of his own making I
mean it's not like the press has 21 make
up stuff or to uh talk about things that
he's not talking about when a negative
story gets raised he is always feeding
the story and giving the media of uh the
obligation to cover what he is saying uh
so this is a core an example of uh media
management 101 being violated by title
Trump been a matter of the media being
read against Donald Trump Hillary gets
plenty of bad coverage but her team i
would say perfectly but does a far
better job of how to respond to negative
media coverage the Donald Trump does do
are you worried that as a result of some
of the coverage as a result of claims of
a rigged election or not rigged election
is there any concern that the sort of
net effect of all of this might lead uh
would be hillary clinton voters not to
vote either an early vote
or on Election Day in a way that could
impact some swing states well this is
the big wild card that you really cannot
discern from poles there was a question
before the komi announcement when all
the polling showed sizable leads for
Clinton how would that affect turn out
with that cause complacency on the
Democratic side with that cause
resignation on the Republican side with
that boost third party vote voting
because there wouldn't be a sense of of
concern of being a spoiler or third
party won't be depressed because they'd
have a lot of money knocking a lot of
media attention so there's all sorts of
unknowns there uh now with the komi
announcement regardless of the polling
there is at least a sense in trunk world
that the race is more winnable so
perhaps you would have a boost in
Republican turnout relative to what you
might have had a week ago but you also
may have a surgeon democratic turnout
because now that sense of complacency is
being mitigated uh and maybe that all
depresses third party turn out because
maybe maybe I'm gonna be a spoiler sigh
should be look carefully about that
there's all sorts of unknowns here that
uh you were just not going to be able to
really know until the voting actually
occurs well that is already happening in
terms of early and absentee ballots and
we're only a week away from november
eight so we'll we'll be able to end the
speculation soon and just have actual
numbers which i don't know about you
bill but I'm ready to move on at this
point you'll miss it you'll miss this
election with it's over bill scher
editor at our future dot org
contributing editor at Politico thanks
as always bill my pleasure